we're so caught up in the outcome that
we forget about the process to live
better we have to tune into the process
we have to tap into the present moment
to let go of fear because the power is
in the now a lot of us we just want this
lifestyle but we don't want to put in
the work we don't want to pay our dues
we don't want to be patient
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
special that can change the planet so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from youtuber author and
life coach Ralph smart and my take on
his top ten rules of success
[Music]
create value so long as you are creating
value for the world you have nothing to
worry about you will be living in
infinite abundance it's happened to me
along my journey because it all starts
with the idea people like Steve Jobs
they had this idea for Apple right that
idea is so powerful because it impacted
people all around the world billions of
people so create value there was a time
where I used to reach into my pockets
and it was empty then I got a job and I
would reach into my pockets and guess
what it was empty
then I started to do what I love and a
big smile I'm breathing in that fresh
prana baby so I'm balancing my mind
which gives me more clarity which helps
me become a better attractor ok because
there are many celebrities with
so-called a lot of money I think can us
once said I sold my soul to the devil
for a crappy deal all I got was a few
toys and a happy meal you've got a
listen Bob Dylan also try to tell people
you see because it's not about what
looks good on paper
it's what looks good to you now freedom
is very important you see when you are
growing up when you're a child when they
say what you want to be when you grow up
what do you want to be when you grow up
many of us we don't say I want to become
rich we say I want to do what the hell I
want to do so freedom that's what we
think money is ok once you have a lot of
money guess what
you can do whatever you want to do so
you have to ask yourself is money
preventing me from doing what I really
want to do is money preventing me from
doing what I really want to do and then
you've got to ask yourself what are my
core needs my core desires and how am i
meeting and fulfilling them for me my
core need is to get out into nature and
that's what makes me feel like a walking
billionaire and guess what I am I am
wealth the good life everyone wants the
good life for some people it may be
relaxing on a beach for some people it
may be traveling infinite freedom people
spend thousands of pounds or dollars to
go to university to study to get a job
so all of us so many of us on the planet
we are always striving for something
we're striving for the better life
what's helped me on my journey is to see
the secret many of us we're so caught up
in the outcome that we forget about the
process to live better we have to tune
into the process which is the present
moment many of us we're working day in
day out but in the process we are
killing ourselves and by the time we
have what we want
it doesn't even matter anymore so on my
journey I say I am already there it's
fantastic
I don't say I want happiness I remove
the eye which is the ego the one which
is the desire I say happiness stop
multitasking like
I used to do so many different things I
used to actually work in different jobs
like do this do that
see the problem about multitasking some
people can do it but the problem is like
whatever you're doing like those
different things they're gonna suffer
like you're gonna do lots of different
things really badly so when I make
videos and Finnick waters I'm just doing
this like I do consultations I just do
that I don't do a whole lot but I have a
lot of concentrated focus on one thing
for a sustained period of time which is
why we bloom and blossom baby but you
don't want to do that deep you like I
want to open up a gym Ralph a restaurant
too now I'm taking my kids for a walk
then I'm going cycling then I'm going to
the beach then I'm doing this then I'm
doing that then I'm doing my goodness
gracious
you're giving yourself way too much to
do you're making it harder than it has
to be and that's why you lose the
enthusiasm for what you want to do so
you know end up becoming productive at
all so to become more productive just do
one thing and do it well or just have
fun doing it whatever you want to do how
do we overcome the fear any fear doesn't
matter what it is fear is false evidence
appearing real
my definition of fear is fear is a self
created feeling emanating from an
imaginary belief based on the illusion
of separation fear is never in the
present moment
fear is either in the past or the future
therefore we have to tap into the
present moment to let go of fear because
the power is in the now there are so
many things to be afraid of in the world
we're living in
but we have to remember that fear is the
greatest energy vampire the more we are
in fear the more we lose our energy a
great way I've found to overcome fear is
to face your fear
look your fear straight in the eyes feel
the fear and do it anyway
you have to go for it we have to embrace
this challenge fear is offering to us
because fear is always making us rise
higher I have to ask yourself am I gonna
invest in my talent to produce enough
passion when I was making videos back in
the day guess what I invested in a
really good camera I bought a Canon 5d
Mark - and a lens which cost $1000 canon
1.2 even I thought I was crazy okay I
thought I was crazy but deep down I knew
that I was entering the loft exchange
you've got to give something before you
get something a lot of us we just want
this lifestyle but we don't want to put
in the work we don't want to pay our
dues we don't want to be patient we
don't want to read we don't want to
study love yourself a hundred percent
not worrying what other people think is
the greatest form of self love when self
love is absent you will always be
worrying what other people think people
that love themselves we see them all the
time in the world and they're smiling
they're letting go of fear letting go
and they are soaring to phenomenal
heights we've all gone into the streets
and we've seen people singing or playing
the guitar in the middle of the road the
more your self-love increases the more
your self-expression increases and that
is the secret hug yourself when we talk
of living better
what's helped me is being at one with
nature planting our feet surrendering to
nature it does wonders just to bring us
back into divine alignment because many
of us on the planet we've become
disconnected not only from nature but
from ourselves and from one another
nature whether it's a park near where
you live whether it's seeing the ocean
the glorious waves you just get inspired
which is the breath of life comes free
right now you can do anything you can be
anything and yes obstacles will come
along but once again we are living in a
whole new world some people are making a
living of just making videos one of my
favorite youtubers jenna Marbles
genius just a short video every single
week but she's creating abundance what
about Michelle Phan right makeup she
started way back in the day but now
she's created something for herself and
once again there's there's always gonna
be obstacles right this ain't Paradise
Island out here right here in the jungle
in the jungle you don't know what to
expect there's all kinds of creatures so
you gotta ask yourself am i surrounding
myself with people that actually
encouraging me to follow my vision and
my dream or am i surrounding myself with
what can you wear schools these are the
dream killers right setbacks allow us to
set our us down and scratch our head to
say what am i doing
we don't want to do that we spend most
of our time getting away from ourselves
so what's helped me along my journey is
to actually see setbacks as a way the
universe is telling me I better step my
ass down because what we often think as
an as an unfortunate event as an
unfortunate event could be a blessing in
disguise
slow motion away
I had two laptops blow up in front of me
not nice I had to buy new ones but
actually the newer ones I go are a lot
better faster seven day vegan challenge
alert I had a lot of setbacks growing up
sometimes I would say gosh why aren't I
in that place
why aren't I where I want to be in the
perfect career and you see how the law
of attraction works is that we attract
what we are energetically to us
so look at it like this if you have a
setback or a massive disappointment what
is gonna happen you are now gonna start
mirroring back that same energetic
vibration so if you're feeling really
grumpy because of a setback creates a
snowball effect you're gonna be more
grumpy more grumpy more grumpy and it's
even gonna be a greater set back to you
so you've got to become an alchemist
which the secret of alchemy is making
the best out of the worst when you fall
down and not allowing external events to
govern your internal condition
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because big man Tate 736
for asked me to if there's someone you'd
like to vote on for the next top 10
check out the link in the description
and go and have your say finally I want
to give a quick shout out to Becky sisa
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and doing the
review that you posted on your website
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
when you are really happy when you are
feeling good what happens some people
say I feel like a million dollars
I feel priceless that's what you should
be saying but when you're really
miserable when you're really tired
depressed someone might even give you
money but you feel like your pockets are
empty so once you start realizing the
money we attract is based linked and
connected to the emotions we are feeling
in the present moment as soon as I
started to love myself a hundred percent
what happened I came to realize that I
was a walking billionaire no I was
priceless
yes there is no sum of money anybody can
put on you
so stop changing how you feel about
yourself to start changing what you
attract into your life a lot of the
times we get lazy we get tired but
what's helped me along my journey is to
realize sometimes the TV which tells
lies to your vision can make you even
more tired and lazy sell your TV right
now it's a little much message mmm
actually don't sell it keep it just move
to the other room right that's what
helped me along my journey I actually
got rid of my TV so sometimes will come
into my house and say gosh you you don't
have a TV in here you got that right
that's why I'm creating so much right
that's why I'm creating so much because
buy the TV is great if you use it in the
right way sometimes as a program you
want to watch but these days like a lot
of the TV channels are just small
programming for you like mind control
and stuff like you can just go on the
internet what
whatever you want whenever you want
however you want and have more fun and
also be more prudent be more productive
because you see you don't have to just
sit down and consume information on the
internet you can actually create
information how about that and become
more productive you can't please
everyone that's another secret many of
us we say please like me please love me
to everyone we have to remind ourselves
we are not in this world to live up to
other people's expectations we are in
this world to be ourselves in essence
tune in to our authenticity a hundred
percent
some people love you one day then they
hate you the next day then they love you
again what matters most to you how do
you see yourself that is essential
because people's opinions of you are
always changing however how you see
yourself stays with you forever
the perception we have of ourselves is
greater than the perception other people
have of us